hello everyone good afternoon my name is
Jake ooh and today I will be talking
about external memory data structures
for tables and graphs so I'm the
co-founder and a software engineer at
dado have a master's degree in machine
learning from Carnegie Mellon University
for my research I did a distributed
graph partitioning and i am the
co-author of the power graph paper what
is dado dollars formerly known as
GraphLab where the young startup funded
in 2013 by professor colors question and
his grad students including me and our
mission is to accelerate the creation of
intelligent applications we provide
providing scalable data engineering
tools high level machine learning
building blocks and model deployment
management tools for machine learning in
production enough of the introduction
let me begin the talk by sharing with
you a tweet from the recent data
scientist comment a data science summit
it says data scientists spends a lot of
time cleaning about data and the rest of
time complaining about cleaning the
updated feel free to retweet it and what
are they complaining about the pain
point includes running out of memory
when your data set doesn't fit in memory
your computer starts swapping it freezes
there's absolutely nothing you can do
about it it's absolutely painful so
sometimes people do data subsampling to
bring the data size down to a size which
fits into the memory however it
introduced uncertainties about your
models and also huge overhead of model
management in the data management which
which subsample does my data come from
and which model which subset does the
data are causes this model right another
way is to use shared cluster in big data
systems however these systems has huge
overhead as well when every time you run
the hive query you know it's time to go
for a long walk and even if after you
come back it's not guaranteed to succeed
because you're sharing the results with
everyone and the container size has
limit your job might get killed and you
have to restart all start over
so these pain points are caused by the
lack of fast scalable and easy to use
external memory data structures this is
what I'm going to talk about today ask
yourself would I be more productive if i
can analyze lots of data without doing
stop sampling using just my laptop and
doing it interactively so with this
question as our motivation we start to
look for ways to push the limit of a
single machine with fast scalable and
easy to use data structures for machine
learning applications to understand the
performance of a single machine it is
critical to look at the storage
hierarchy picture here we have spinning
hard disks SSDs and memory with memory
you can get you can get a very large
troop about 10 gigabytes per second
however you can only work with data at
about the same size 0 discs and SSDs
have decent throughput and their
capacity lets you scale to hors
d'oeuvres data sets with audit of orders
of magnitudes larger however the caveat
is that random access on these disks are
really really slow so a good external
memory and data structure needs to
understand all these considerations and
this is what I'm going to talk about so
the rest of the talk is organized into
three parts I'm first begin by talking
about s frame our scalable tabular data
manipulation and then we'll talk about
graph data data manipulation and finally
I will talk about how do we are use s
frames and graphs in the distributor
setting so your data usually begins as
rows for example this netflix data set
has rows of records about user ID movie
ID and ratings so when you do data
engineering your transformation is
usually in doing it on columns so we can
normalize the rating columns by dividing
every value by toto song we want to
create a new column a feature called
ratings squared by just square every
value on in the rating column
for example we can also substitute
olives and make it a new data set these
are all columnar transformations so the
first class citizen of s frame is called
s array or scalable array which is
beautiful representing a single typed
column Ezra is backed by disk and it's
immutable once it's written on to disk
it's never going to change an SRA can
hold a rich type rich of column types
starting from traditional integer float
numerical data or string for text data
to more interesting data types like
daytime for time series and images on
top of it we also support recursive
types like list of any of the types
above and dictionary for any of the
types of evolved links list and
dictionary allows us to easily work with
JSON list and JSON array and also
dictionary is a good representation for
sparse data like bag of words
representation so these design are
driven by real world use case looking at
this yoke reveal data we can read this
into s frame in just one line of read
CSV and all the columns are
automatically parsed for example here we
have the business ID column which are
string date which is daytime starts our
ratings with integer type texts the
other reviews and here this is an
interesting dictionary column called
votes basically saying how many people
think this restaurant I think this
review is funny how many people think
this review is useful and at the end we
have a list of strings as our category
categories for this business so with sra
s frame representation is really simple
you can think of it as a dictionary
which maps a column name to end data
which is stored into in an SRA so for
instance where we load in this frame as
firm is just a collection of column
names pointing to the data we can load
as similar as frame
and then assign a column from one of
this frame to the other this is simply
by creating a new entry in the
dictionary and then points to the data
which is on the disk so this is
representation is very simple but it's
highly scalable in fact there's no real
number of row limit for how many rows
are in s frame can store as long as you
have enough disk practically you can
store about hundred to a thousand
columns the reason for the column limit
is because our race our files and there
are a limit of limited number of file
handles you can open at the same time
for the are on your system so the
largest s frame we have tried has about
a thousand columns and ten Billy rose
this is in total 10 trillion dense
numeric values and today I'm going to
show you this in real
you
everyone is here is i think is familiar
with the side python notebook as framing
or our product GraphLab create is a
python package we begin by import the
package GraphLab and then we load this
data from this let's print how many rows
and the columns there are 950 columns
and close to 10 million rows let's
quickly look at the content of this data
so this is a big synthetic data set are
representing a biological data set we
have a response column y and a bunch of
numerical columns for each of all the
features they are a bunch of zeros and
ones and also we have floating we have
the float columns at the end lots of
lots of columns so here we just printed
the first 10 rows and now let's do a
columnar our operation let's take this
our feature called pre for cons and
compute a variance of it so calculating
the variance of 10 billion values only
take 0.03 seconds let's do some feature
engineering by creating a new feature
called this hour reflects a orgy by
doing all operation which is a
vectorized operation between two columns
and the result is assigned into a new
column called reflects a orgy this is
very fast almost instantly and then we
can delete this column which is for free
let's film cans go to this big large
data set but even more exciting we can
scale all the non pi to the same scale
by using s frame back as a PEZ its back
end so here is how it works our numpy
integration imported regular numpy and
you import GraphLab door numpy after
that let's dump this entire s frame with
tential and numerical values into an
umpire ray so let's print out the type
of this non pi data variable
which is the non-tidal in the array and
the size is 99.9 three ninety nine point
three billion by nine fifty let's do a
quick calculation about how much memory
it would take if you would store it
naively it takes six point four
terabytes of memory it's even much it's
even bigger than the entire disk space
we have on this machine this is probably
the world's largest number you have ever
seen and yet we can do our or standard
numpy operations like indexing like
changing the values of the first row
into one and after you look at it it's
the first row has been changed to all
ones we can even run cycle and
algorithms on this big numpy array and
here for the four inches of time I'm
only doing it on a hundred thousand
subset of this number of this data so we
have this cyclone model the nuclear SGD
classifier running on the data so this
is super awesome
let's dive a little bit a little bit
into how we make how we make this happen
the first secret sauce is called lazy
evaluation and query optimization by
lazy evaluation we want to avoid writing
to disk whenever possible when you
perform a serious computation on an
eskimo sra say i want 2 + 2 + 3 + + 5 we
don't evaluate it immediately because
evaluating it will cause us to
materialize in entire s array on the
disk which is very costly instead we
build this a chain of operations we
remember the computation rather than
evaluate them immediately and only until
you want to ask for the result do we
carry out the entire of computation
graph at once this avoids are to write
in to disk whenever possible also
because we have this query plan laid out
in front of us we can perform all sorts
of classic sequel type our optimization
to make it even more efficient here's an
example of lazy evaluation let's load up
a spring which is a source node of s
frame stored on disk we projector one
column or select one common core rating
we applied times 2 on this rating column
and then let's let's put it back into
this room again and we project it out
and computer some on top of it so all
these is we can we can perform this
entire computation without creating you
as a race and with query optimization we
can merge owed on nodes that are merge
abou what we can push our filter and
project upwards and push drawings
downwards to make it more efficient so
this is the optimize the query plan that
we are really using edn so it's just
taking as a resource for each value x 2
and then you sum them together so this
is a more crazy example of query plan
before optimized and after optimization
this makes us from really
really efficient on a bench mark from
the Berkeley amp love is for this query
which is about select two columns from a
table and then do a logical filter with
PageRank greater than 100 so our SOS
frame is comparable to all those big
data systems and it's even faster than
the Red Hood than the then rush up to
which keep things in memory this is not
the end of the story all those systems
are running out five machine whereas
GraphLab create only runs on one machine
okay so this is about the computation
side of s frame now let's look at the
storage site the second secret secret
sauce which make s frame so efficient is
what we call a type wear compression
because each column stores data of the
same type we can use compression
algorithms that best suits the column
type for example for integer data we use
frames frame of reference encoding or
Delta encoding for floated a time we
cast it to integer and reuse the integer
compression for string if you don't have
many unique values we can replace the
string with it with a dictionary or with
the ID inside a dictionary this is
called dictionary encoding and of course
for images are we can we can use JPEG or
PNG encodings which is way more
efficient than using a 2d array naively
so looking at this netflix data set with
a hundred million rows and three integer
columns if you represent if you stole on
this naively as text it takes 1.4 gigs
of ram if you load it into pandas
dataframe it's even bigger it's 3
gigabytes if you store it in s frame
it's 160 megabytes maybe but it's even
better even smaller than the gzipped
data on the roll gzip on the raw data
because we have this column aware a
column type of wear compression where as
gzip only is a general-purpose
compression algorithm now let's remember
the storage hierarchy with these are
throughput if we have 10
compression ratio the effective
throughput of these hard words are
increased by and orders of magnitude
which makes them even closer to the
memory speed so this is the second
secret source of aspirin type a type of
wear compression so however external
memory data structures are awesome but
this is only part of the story because
in these external memory algorithms to
work with it because existing a lot of
existing machine learning algorithms or
implementation of them have random
access a lot of random access which is
killing the performance even when you
have this awesome external that memory
data structure so this calls for us to
rethink all the machine learning
algorithms we don't want to have random
access we like sequential how about
doing a data sampling how do you do it
naive sampling has a too many random
access how about reservoir sampling try
hard not to do sort and shuffle and we
really like algorithms that are
implemented based on mini batch
iterators so with this in mind we
implement a wide range of machine
learning algorithms which are external
memory data structure friendly and for
this Cagle it has that for this critical
data set for the cattle competition the
goal is to predict the click rate has 46
million rows and 34 million sparse
coefficients and for the this is the
berkeley project bit mac which is one of
one node and one GPU it runs 10
iterations of SGD takes 800 seconds and
for GraphLab create on cpu run 10
iterations of l bfgs which is even more
expensive takes only 600 seconds this is
because not the custody PU is slow it's
because this task is not compute bound
it's really i/o bound so as long as you
can bring the data in more efficiently
faster you can easily beat a GPU
this frame is also built with a
usability in mind so it's a python api
we will have our student it's built with
a lightning-fast csv passer which helps
you to get a data in as soon as fast as
possible with json support if you have a
column with json string it automatically
parts it into a dictionary column which
is awesome it has integrations with non
pie you guys have seeing it with two
pandas you can bring data from a
database from using odbc driver we also
have an integration with spark our dd's
looking at the column you might want to
ask various questions about what's the
minimum me max quantiles on number of
uniques we have a one-pass of square
sketch summary which does one part of
the data and gives you all these answers
also it finally comes with a nice
visualizations which I can show you
offline so in summary in one sentence as
frame is this compressed column table
supporting rich data types using type of
work compression and lazy evaluation to
achieve high throughput in interactive
speed on large data next let's talk
about let's talk about s graph graph
data sets are getting increasingly more
popular graphing codes relationships
between people facts ideas and interests
graph can be really big but a big graph
contains trillions of vertices and edges
and rich metadata and we built this s
graph which is a immutable disk back to
graph representation supporting our
arbitrary attributes for vertex and
edges and it's optimized for bulk query
access like getting the neighborhood of
5 million vertices it is not optimized
for fine where queries like get the
neighborhood of one vertex how do we
build s graph sqf is built on top of s
frames the layout works this way first
we partition all the
vertex data into a collection of of s
frames in this case let's say for s
frames the the partitioning can be
arbitrary we just use a simple hash
function to have a vertex ID into into a
partition ID in each of the s frame
contains ID column and the rest of the
columns are just arbitrary meta data you
want to associate with the vertex
because it's a s frame everything is
stored on disk everything is stored in
common columnar now how do we partition
any edges we partition the edges into 16
which is P Square as frames each
partition is also having also have to ID
columns and the metadata columns what
are the coordinates for this is
basically a course or coarse grained
adjacency matrix if you want to if we
look at the edges that are in partition
to come up for it only contains vertices
from partition to to partition for so
this allows for instance if I want to
compute for this sub graph all I need is
to load vertex 2 and vertex 4 in memory
or partition to and partition for
similarly if one if I want to get
adjacency structures of all the vertices
in partition to I only need to look at
these set of vertices sorry edges um
finally on this is very important we as
frame-up n is zero cost you can easily
append are multiple s frames and they're
very lazily concatenated together so
this allows us for example to represent
entire vertex table as a single s frame
by doing a zero concatenation a
zero-cost concatenation of all the
vertex s frames and all the are all the
s frames for edges so the API for data
engineering on graph looks exactly the
data engineering on tables for example
we can sum all the paid ranks on the
vertex autumn vertices by doing jido
vertices page rank or some this is
exactly what you would do for tables
even though the vertex has all those of
is partitioned into a collection of s
films so we we hide all the
implementation details which allows you
to seamlessly transition from graphs and
between graphs and tables however
looking at this representation it's
still a little bit wasteful we can do
better looking at these are ids columns
on edges they are strings this is very
common because the vertex ID can be
username email address or social
security number and storing the these
these information as is are wasteful and
redundant because we already have all
these strings as ID in the vertex table
so what we do is for each vertex
partition we have we can use the role ID
which is in implicit numbering and just
replace the source ID and Destin ID
destination ID in edge s frame with
these sink integers or offset in your
partition so this result in extremely
compressible format for our edges
usually you have a lot more edges than
vertices because all integers are very
small so for this common CRO of web
graph with 3.5 billion vertices and 128
building edges this is the largest
available public graph store it naively
would cause 2 terabytes of memory or
disk space with these awesome
compression it only takes 200 gigabytes
this is again about a 10 to 1
compression ratio also increase the
throughput of our graph algorithms on
one are easy to instance are 3x large
and one SSD we can perform page rank on
this big graph at speed of nine minutes
per iteration and connected components
runs through run until convergence takes
it about an hour there's not really any
general purpose library today can
achieve this our single machine even
distributed so in summary or for all for
the S graph all you need to remember is
this picture of this simple graph layout
this allows us to optimize for our old
query and with this implicit edge IDs
and compression a comes free with SRAM
we can achieve very high edge throughput
and also you can do a graph data
engineering as easy as table data
engineering ok we have talked about
tables and grouse and so far their lives
on single machine how do we go
distribute it I've advocated we stay in
two in a single machine as as as long as
possible and avoid distributed computing
but many people here have Hadoop
clusters they want to use it and the
doing distributed allows you to train on
larger even larger data set with even
faster speed so let's see how it works
in the distributor setting say you have
this one machine and you want to make
one pass over the data it takes a
hundred seconds with two machines each
machine have half of beta now making one
pass of a data takes half of time you
essentially have parallel disk however
this is only for embarrassingly parallel
tasks like map for a lot of machine
learning algorithms this is not that
simple usually it comes with this
pattern you start with your data set
each machine to do a sweep over the over
its part and then you synchronize the
parameters and then you do this again
again until the parameter
virgins so the first part is to make
sure that they talk is evenly a
partitioned onto your nodes and we can
do achieve this embarrassingly parallel
in the second part is we want to talk as
fast as possible so on top of s women
will also build a very fast RPC
communication layer which allows to
allow us to the efficient communication
about those parameters so remember that
critical data set which is for Carol
it's the subset for a full data set
which is hundred armed times larger with
16 machines we can run run to full
convergence in barely minutes note that
you can still do it on a single machine
it just takes an hour we achieve linear
speed-up by using this parallel disk
plus our efficient communication so this
is about machine learning distributed
machine learning or a spring what about
distributed graphs graphs are even
trickier to to to run named distributed
this is because graph partitioning zar
challenging so here we just take the s
graph all those edges and then evilly
partition them onto each of the machine
so each vertices will appear no more
than are because because of this I
adjacency structures each vertex will
show up on no more than two square root
of P minus 1 machines this is the total
amount of communication is the upper
bound of the communication you will have
while doing graphic communication oo
doing graph computation so here's the
slice from couple years ago about
paragraph um maybe three years ago so we
run on this out of this Tiger web graph
with think 32 machines which has six
point six billion edges at the speed of
seven seconds per iteration for page
rank and today with new partitioning
algorithms and and efficient external
memory data structures was 16 machine we
could
run it on run a much larger common
Chrome web graph at the speed of 45
seconds per iteration that is three
building edges per second so to conclude
we talk about efficient memory data
structures that are key to the
productivity of data scientist we
describe the SMS graph that skills two
terabytes of data or hundreds of
billions of the edges of graph on a
single machine at the interactive speed
finally we can run faster in the scale
to even larger it as that when using
these data structures in distributor
setting so finally I want to say that a
date all we care about performance
deeply but it is not just about speed or
scaling because it's really easy
especially for large companies to throw
a lot of machines to reach the speed and
to reach to solve the problem or be some
benchmarks a data where we think about
performance or scalability while
building systems it's about doing more
with what you already have thank
dado el dedo i believe is portuguese
spanish a data in portuguese finish yeah
dog logo because of our CEO professor
colors question had a librado in packing
Pittsburgh that's also where the first
the open source project GraphLab the lab
came from and we keep the dog and and by
the way our experimental S curve will be
open source that in bsd license I think
you should be having relatively soon and
so encourage the Python community to use
it and build more efficient or external
memory friendly algorithms on top of it
yes
in a different language our good
question um estimate is graph the
backend is built in C++ for performance
and the Python is just a front end
language that interface with the backend
to develop efficient algorithms on top
of as friends we have SDK c++ SDK which
you can write algorithms that interfaces
with a widow with an iterator from s
frame that's what I'm activating for
more mini batch iterator based machine
learning algorithms and those are really
the key to interface with external
memory data structures so once you build
those are using SDK you can import it
into imported as a Python module and use
it together with this frame also with
the open source code you can use a even
lower level of s prime representations
that allows you to do more tight
integration with this data structure
from pandas right now is we have to dump
all the data from a sperm into the
memory because panda is in memory and
you have to make sure you have enough
data in a enough memory to hold a data
set and pay for the loading it's not
lazy it's relatively efficient I would
say you can still load a swim into data
frame with maybe 10,000 rows 100,000
rows about that scale but with numpy
it's as it's done differently for numpy
we do we map as frame to an umpire rate
lazily we don't we don't bring all the
data into memory what we do is we is a
genius hack we did we intercepted malloc
function of numpy when you went when my
tries to allocate a large chunk of
memory we redirect it into our
implementation of memory allocation
functions and then we page
in data from s frame and we page data
out into a spring yes sorry can you
repeat your question we are developing
our interface so that you can use it in
our but the back end is really of a C++
back end which we can develop other
foreign language interface to to use it
community provided API far as friends
Oh possible but that is different from
as women neck scrub it's probably the
graph that open source project that our
dates back to a few years ago by the way
there is this confusion about the name
GraphLab or GraphLab can refer to an
open source project that we we developed
during grad school they can refer to the
previous name of the company but right
now our company is called data and the
product is called GraphLab create so
GraphLab create contains all the
external memory data structures
algorithms graph algorithms recommend
their work algorithms and deployment
tools and the open source we are still
thinking about a name which is available
on pi PI and meaningful and interesting
so if you have any suggestion about the
naming of open source project come talk
to me graph pot hot hmm yeah puppy all
right thank you let's give a j.crew a
nice round of applause thank you so much